[Music]
she is currently the most powerful
showrunner in television period Shonda
Rimes is inducted into the television
Academy Hall of Fame when you started
with Grey's Anatomy 300 episodes ago did
you have that dream in your head that
TGI tee would become this cultural
phenomenon and you have that dream for
yourself
um I think you know I always said like
oh I'm gonna take over the world through
television and that sounded fun but I
thought I was just gonna be writing
shows and enjoying myself and hopefully
somebody would watch them I have ever
dreamed of this I feel so lucky that
I've gotten to work with some of the
amazing people and that we form such
great moms and have these amazing
relationships that have lasted so long
it's it's been amazing to me that this
has been my career as West Florida et
chatted with the showrunner on the red
carpet about the end of scandal and the
start of a new chapter in her career so
Netflix I mean are you already the
creative juices going are we gonna see
some familiar faces well I mean yeah I
mean we've already started working there
so to me I'm very excited about what
comes next and I don't know if we're
gonna see create unfamiliar faces I
think so yeah yeah the winter season of
scandals coming up can you describe it
in three words oh I can't describe it in
three words now three is too few or too
many I don't know I it's too much and I
want them to understand who's fight they
stepped into and then I want them
finished I love the fact that you guys
have sent Olivia Pope off the rails this
season viii I'm enjoying every bit of it
can she make her way back to the white
hat or she just too far you know what's
wonderful about this season is that
Carrie is throwing herself into it and
we're throwing ourselves into one of the
writers are going crazy and the cast is
really it's our last season you know
we're telling all the story we want to
tell where she'll end up
I'm not gonna tell you that but I do
think this is a journey for her and
we're going to the place that I've
always wanted her to go what's the vibe
in like on this set because essentially
you are doing everything for the last
time there's a lot of nostalgia there
has been a lot of Tears at certain
points and then a lot of times it's just
been a lot of joy there is a sense that
everything is the last time and so you
hold on to it but I also think you know
I'm in denial about a lot of it so I
just try to pretend that it's gonna keep
going
[Music]